toujours essayé de donner de
l'information pas de nid de contrer de
l'information fausse parce que parfois
ça me semble contre-productif ont en
tout cas fait c'est vraiment lutter
contre des moulins en quoi de contrer la
fausse information a tout le temps de la
prise d'information
[Musique]
à
bon
[Musique]
hop
on se rend compte que ça va être une
problématique très importante très vite
dès fin janvier
puisqu'on mais l'ensemble de nos
ressources clinique de recherche pour
cette pathologie qu'ovide on était
complètement débordé quoi il ya une
explosion extrêmement rapide des cas et
puis ça a été très dur sur le plan
médical parce que c'était patients très
sévère qui mouraient beaucoup qui
m'aurait parfois très vite et pour
lesquelles on n'avait pas de traitement
efficace donc c'est pour ça qu'on on
sait d'emblée lancé notamment à bichat
dans la recherche de traitements
efficaces
[Musique]
c'était un moyen de partager de
l'information au grand public et donc
c'est vrai quand on voit que la position
dominante sur le plan médiatique en tout
cas c'est celle qui correspond pas aux
données de la science et la médecine
donc notamment plus de roxy chloroquine
marche ou le coc vide c'est une maladie
bénigne ou ça se transmet par voie
aérienne enfin tout ce qu'on a entendu
quand on sait de par la pratique qu'on a
que c'est faux et ça me semblait
important en tout cas de donner les
informations que nous on avait c'est à
dire c'est une pathologie extrêmement
grave
c'est une pathologie pour laquelle
malheureusement on n'a pas de traitement
antiviral efficace
[Musique]
je pense la communauté médicale et
scientifique a un peu tardé avant de se
rendre compte de l'ampleur
prenez les messages les fakes news quoi
qui étaient défectueuses presque
institutionnel sur le plan médical
ce qu'elle venait d'un organisme de
recherche et médical reconnu
c'était particulièrement difficile de
lutter contre cette parole
même pour nous évaluer des traitements
on se retrouvait à proposer aux gens de
participer à des essais où on évaluer
différentes molécules alors que ce
qu'ils entendaient par tous c'est qu'il
y avait un traitement efficace déjà ce
qui ne correspondait pas du tout aux
données médicales ou scientifiques est
donc bon sens pour moi c'est un élément
qui est marquant dans cette pandémie
[Musique]
depuis quelques mois ce pourquoi je
dépense de l'énergie c'est vraiment la
vaccination parce que c'est la première
porte de sortie valable je participe
beaucoup à des projets sur le vaccin
donc pour partager de l'information pour
donner les connaissances qu'on a pour
voilà je pense que c'est aussi important
d'avoir un peu un retour terrain pour
les gens croient que ses paroles soient
pas uniquement institutionnels
gouvernementales qu'elles sont décalés
de la pratique est donnée cette
expérience du quotidien que nous qui
sommes dans un service prendre en charge
des patients qu'ovide tous les patients
très fragile qui avaient des pathologies
extrêmement sévère dans la mortalité
était terrible patients transplantés les
patients immunodéprimés les patients
très âgés
depuis qu'ils sont maxine et on les voit
plus avec des formes sévères ou
quasiment pour
[Musique]
le